welcome back and just continuing on with
these uh with with hopefully giving us
what one how to actually solve
indefinite integrals and also giving you
a sense of
of why uh you solve it the way you do
and i think that's that's often missing
in um
in some some textbooks but anyway let's
say that this is the distance so let me
give you a formula actually for the
distance just just for fun
let's say oh my phone is ringing
let me uh lower the volume because
you're more important
so let's say that the distance
s this time i'll write it as a function
let's say the distance is i don't know i
mean i said it started at five so let's
say it's
i don't know two t let's say this is
actually a cube cubic function here
you're going you're not only you're not
only accelerating your rate of
acceleration is increasing and i think
actually the rate of acceleration if i'm
not mistaken is actually called jerk but
i might have to wikipedia that um so
let's say it's 2 2t to the third plus
five
and let's say i wanted to know how far
i travel between time
between t equals
i don't know two seconds
and t equals five seconds
right i'm not looking for the total
distance that travel i just want to know
how far do i travel between time equals
two seconds and time equals 5 seconds
right so this might be
and this is 5.
so an easy way to do that is i could
just evaluate this function
at t equals 5. let me use a different
color i think it's getting messy i could
just evaluate this function at t equals
5. everything's so dark
i could evaluate it at t equals 5. let's
see at t equals 5 5 to the third power
is
125.
250. it's 255.
so the object's gone 255 feet at t
equals five right
and then at time equals two
the object's gone how far two to the
third is eight sixteen it's gone 21 feet
right so we can adjust if
to figure out how far i traveled between
time equals 2 and times equal 5 i just
say s of 5
minus s of 2 right how far did i go over
after 5 seconds minus how far i already
was after two seconds and this is just
minus 21 and that's what 234
to 234 feet is how fire traveled between
two seconds and five seconds
interesting and i think you're starting
to get a little intuition about why we
evaluated that previous indefinite
integral in the previous video the way
we did
so let's let's actually draw the
derivative of this function so what's
what's the derivative so let's say let's
let me just call that v of t i guess
v of t is just the derivative right
because it's the rate of change of
distance with respect to time
so 3 times 2
is 6
t squared and the constant disappears
right so it's just 6t squared and that
that makes sense right because your
velocity doesn't care about where you
started off from right you're going to
be the same velocity if you started from
10 feet or if you started from 2 feet
your velocity doesn't really matter
about where you're your starting
position is so let's graph this
see you're actually learning a little
physics
while you're learning calculus actually
i think it's silly that they're taught
as two separate classes i think physics
and calculus should just be one fun two
hour class but but i'll i'll talk about
that in another time but anyway
um
so going back to this let me graph that
60 squared well that's just going to
look like a parabola right
it's going to look something like this
this is t
this is the velocity
and now if we just had this velocity
graph if we didn't if we didn't know all
of this over here
and i asked you the same question though
i said how far does this
how far does this thing travel between
two seconds
and
and five seconds
right between two seconds
and five seconds well i could i could do
it the way that we learned in the
previous video where i draw a bunch of
small rectangles you know each of a
really small width and i'm and i
multiply it times its instantaneous
velocity at that exact moment
right and then i and then i whoops
and then i sum up all of those
rectangles
all right look how pretty that is
i sum up all of the rectangles
and i'll get a pretty good approximation
for
for how far i've traveled between two
and five seconds right
because remember
each of these rectangles represent the
area of each of these rectangles
represents how far i traveled in that
little you know that little amount of
time dt right because time times
times the constant velocity is equal to
distance right but as you can see this
also tells me the area
between t equals five and t equals
that's that's an ugly it's an ugly color
between t equals
between t equals two and t equals five
right so not only did i figure out the
distance between those how far did i
travel from
two seconds to five seconds i also
figured out the area under this curve
from two seconds to five seconds so
interestingly enough if if i just change
this from a to b
a to b and in general if you want to
figure out the area under a curve from a
to b
it's just
the indefinite integral from
a
to b
actually from b to a the b should be the
larger one
b to a
i guess a to b depending on how you say
it let me write that in a different
color because i think i'm right making
it messier from a to b
of this velocity function so in this
case
6t squared
dt right if i if these weren't 2 and 5
this was just a and b
and the way you evaluate this is you
figure out the antiderivative of this
inside
function right and then you evaluate the
anti-derivative at b and then from that
you subtract it out at a so let's say so
in this case the anti-derivative of this
is
2t to the third two t to the third
and we evaluated at b and we evaluated a
or l actually let me stick to the old
numbers we evaluated at five and you
evaluated it at two
so if you evaluated at 5
that's uh
255 and if you've got it two that's 21.
so you're doing the exact same thing we
did here when we actually had this graph
so i i did all of this just to not
confuse you further but but really just
to give you an intuition of why one why
the anti-derivative is the area under
the curve and then two why
let's say that
y
a b
and then why we evaluate it this way
you might see this in a in in your books
this is just saying that if if i want to
figure out the area under a curve from
b from a to b of f of x
that we figure out the anti-derivative
this capital f is just the
anti-derivative right or it's just the
anti-derivative we just figure out the
anti-derivative
and we evaluate it at b
and we evaluate it at a and then we
subtract the difference and that's what
we did here right this is what we did
here intuitively when we worked with
distance i i did this whole distance you
know the derivative and the
anti-derivative don't only apply to
distance and velocity
but i did this to give you an intuition
of why this works and why the
anti-derivative is the area under the
curve so let me clear this up and just
rewrite that last thing i wrote
but maybe a little bit cleaner
okay
so let's say that
f of x with a big fat capital f is equal
to
let's say it's no let me actually let me
do it a better way let me say that the
derivative
of big fat f of x
is equal to f of x
right
so all we're saying i think i think
actually this is the fundamental theorem
of calculus but i don't want to
throw out things without knowing for
sure i have to go
make sure um see i haven't done math in
a long time so i'm giving you all this
based on intuition not necessarily what
i'm i'm reading
but uh so the derivative of big f is is
this small f and all we're saying is
that if we take the integral
of small f of x
from a to b
dx that this is
big f it's anti-derivative at b
minus the anti-derivative at a
in the next presentation i'll use this
and this is actually pretty easy to use
once you know how to use
anti-derivatives and we did these three
videos really just to give you or
actually is this the third or the second
just to give you an intuition of of why
this is because i think that's that's
really important if you're ever going to
really use calculus in your life or
write a computer program or whatever and
in the next couple of videos i'll
actually
apply this to a bunch of problems and
you'll hopefully see that it's a it's a
pretty straightforward
thing to actually compute i'll see in
the next presentation